November is the perfect month for long
nights at home with your TV and Amazon
is delivering plenty of entertainment to
keep you occupied from Jack Ryan and
James Bond Christmas comedies and
Hollywood classics here are some fresh
new arrivals coming to Amazon Prime in
November if you're James Bond fan and an
Amazon Prime video subscriber your going
to be very pleased with the streaming
service this November Mr Bond
throughout November Prime's action
offerings will be largely dominated by a
certain agent double-oh 7 beginning with
1962's dr. no and ending with 2002's die
another day nearly the entire James Bond
film library will be available for
streaming on Amazon Prime video on
November 1st
unfortunately the editions don't include
any of Daniel Craig's more recent
entries or the 1967 spoof Casino Royale
but everything else will be there unless
Daniel Craig is your favorite Bond you
should be very pleased indeed settle in
and catch up on all the entries starring
Sean Connery Roger Moore Timothy Dalton
and Pierce Brosnan oh and George Lazenby
sole contribution 1969's on Her
Majesty's Secret Service will be there
too the name is marathon James Bond
marathon most viewers know John
Krasinski for his portrayal of Jim
Halpert on the office and they might
have a tough time buying him as the star
of a political thriller well let's not
be that way
the first season of Jack Ryan earned
plenty of positive reviews and presents
key already proved he's a versatile
actor with a quiet place on November 1st
fans will get their second chance to see
Krasinski fight against terrorism
political corruption and everything in
between
Jack Ryan's first season had lots of
globe-hopping between the States Europe
and the Middle East but for the second
season things are going south Ryan
travels to South America to investigate
illegal arms sales in the Venezuelan
jungle his investigation eventually
uncovers a vast conspiracy involving a
corrupt Venezuelan president secret
dealings with Russia and the possibility
of Venezuela getting its hands on
nuclear weapons do this
I can live with that Amazon Prime video
added lots of horror movies at the end
of September in preparation for
Halloween so if you're tired of the
scares the blood and the gore too bad
because more is on the way on November
1st Tim Burton's 2007 adaptation of the
stage musical Sweeney Todd the Demon
Barber of Fleet Street starts streaming
its stars Johnny Depp as a serial killer
slash barber in 19th century London who
murders his customers with palpable glee
meanwhile his fiendish co-conspirator
played by Helena Bonham Carter turns the
dead bodies into tasty meat pies and
feeds them to unsuspecting customers
it's deliciously good fun if you're
still hungry for more abject terror the
classic 2002 horror film the ring starts
streaming the same day and it revolves
around a cursed videotape that kills
whoever watches it if you're looking for
even more gore prepare yourself for the
2013 horror film Texas Chainsaw which
will be showing up on prime on November
6th and if you're on the hunt for more
classic terror be sure to track down the
1987 thriller fatal attraction which
begins streaming on November 1st Glenn
Close stars as Alex a wildly unhinged
woman whose infatuation with a married
man played by Michael Douglas quickly
takes a turn for the psychotic after
they share a passionate weekend together
this very married man tries to move on
with his life
well that doesn't go over too well
particularly for an ill-fated pit rabbit
[Music]
closest portrayal of the psychotic
spurned lover earned her an Oscar nod
and rightfully so in November Amazon
Prime video is adding two Christmas
themed comedies that are a whole lot
darker than your average holiday fare on
November 1st the service will start
streaming 2003's Bad Santa a highly
irreverent comedy that stars Billy Bob
Thornton as a pitiful foul-mouthed mall
Santa what about the reindeer would you
please shut up about reindeer then
starting on November 13th you can check
out the 2018 film Anna and the
apocalypse starring Ella hunt as a woman
who likes to sing and dance while
killing zombies occasionally killing
them with humongous candy canes Happy
Holidays if you're in no mood for a
holiday themed laugh riot check out the
1991 comedy soap dish instead this
brilliant farce offers a hilarious spin
on daytime soap operas and needless to
say there's just as much drama going on
behind the scenes as in front of the
camera the all-star cast includes Robert
Downey jr. Whoopi Goldberg Elizabeth
Shue Sally Field and many others it's
really good stuff
one of primes November offerings with
the shortest turnaround time from screen
to stream is 2018 s Creed 2 the sequel
to the acclaimed 2015 drama Creed
Michael B Jordan plays Adonis Creed in
both films and he's the son of the late
boxer Apollo Creed played by Carl
Weathers as you might recall Apollo died
fighting a juiced-up Soviet boxer in
1985 s rocky for don't pretend this is
about your father
Sylvester Stallone reprises his role as
Rocky Balboa acting as Adonis's trainer
the second Creed installment sees Adonis
face Victor Drago played by Florian
Montano and he's the son of the man who
killed Adonis's father in the ring
killer boxer Yvonne Drago played by
Dolph Lundgren also returns to stand in
his son's corner repeat something
decided turned this fighter
and if you're looking for a drama with a
bit more mystery and a way darker ending
there's the classic 1974 gumshoe mystery
Chinatown starring Jack Nicholson as
Private Eye Jake Geddes and Faye Dunaway
as his client Chinatown raked in a pile
of Oscar nominations and even nabbed a
win for Best Original Screenplay in 1990
Nicholson directed a sequel the two
Jakes but it wasn't nearly as well
received as its predecessor Chinatown is
absolutely essential viewing so be sure
to investigate this twisted mystery if
you haven't already check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite TV
shows and movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]